Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to learn why you should
not even try to handcuff a computer graphics
researcher. And it’s not because they are criminal
masterminds, no-no! So what is it then? Well,
if they have read this paper, handcuffing them
will not work. See? They will get out easily.
So, what is all this insanity here? Well,
this paper is about simulating repulsion.
Or, to be more exact, computing repulsive
forces on curves and surfaces. Now,
of course, your first question is,
okay, but what is that good for?
Well, believe it or not, it doesn’t sound
like it, but it is good for so many things,
the applications just keep coming and coming.
So, how does this work? Well, repulsion
can prevent intersections and collisions.
And, look at that! If we run this process over
time, it creates flows. In other words, it starts
mingling with the geometry in interesting,
and it turns out, also, useful ways.
For instance, imagine that we have this
tangled handcuff. And someone comes up to us
and says they can untangle this object by
molding, and not only that, but this person gets
even more brazen: they say they even do
it gently, or in other words, without
any intersections. No colliding
or breaking is allowed. Well,
then I say I don’t believe a word of it,
show me! And the person does exactly that.
Using the repulsive force algorithm, we can find a
way to untangle them. This seems like black magic.
With some adjustments to this process, and running
it backwards in time, we can even start with a
piece of geometry, and compute an ideal shrink
wrap for it. Even better, when applied to point
clouds, we can even create a full 3D geometry
that represents these points. And, get this,
even if the point clouds are incomplete! Make no
mistake, the topic of point cloud reconstruction
has been studied for many decades now, so much so
that during my PhD years, I attended well over a
hundred paper talks on this topic. And I am by
no means an expert on this, not even close, but
I can tell you, this looks like a pretty good
solution. And these applications emerge only
a tiny side effect of this algorithm. But
it’s not over. There is more! It can even fix
bad mesh geometries, something that artists
encounter in the wild all the time. Loving it!
And, it can also create cool and crazy
surfaces for your art installations.
Now, so far, we have applied repulsion to
surfaces. But this concept can also be applied
to curves as well, which opens up a whole
new world of really cool applications.
Let’s start with the most important one.
Do you know what happens when you put
your wired earbuds into your pocket?
Yes! Of course, exactly this happens. Every
time, right? And now, hold on to your papers,
because it turns out, it can even untangle
your headphones without breaking them.
Now wait a second…if it can generate curves
that don’t intersect, maybe it could also be
used for path planning for characters in a
virtual world. Look, these folks intersect.
But if they use this new technique for path
planning - there should be no intersections. And,
yes! No intersections, thereby,
no collisions. Excellent.
And if we feel like it, we can also start with
a small piece of noodle inside a bunny and start
growing it. Why not? And then, we can marvel at
how over time, it starts to look like intestines.
And it just still keeps growing and growing
without touching the bunny. So cool!
Now, onto more useful things. It can even be
used to visualize social media connections and
family trees in a compact manner. Or, it can move
muscle fibers around. And the list just goes on.
But you are experienced Fellow Scholars over
there, so I hear you asking, well, wait a second,
all this sounds quite trivial. Just apply
repulsive forces to the entirety of the surfaces,
and off we go. Why does this have to be a paper
published at a prestigious conference? Well,
actually, let’s try this. If we do that…
uh-oh. This happens. Or this happens.
This algorithm is not so trivial after all!
And this is what I love about this paper. It
proposes a simple idea. And this idea is simple,
but not easy. If we think it is easy, this
happens. If we do it well, this happens.
The paper describes in detail how to perform
this so it works properly, and provides a ton
of immediate things it can be used to. This is not
a product, this is an idea and a list of potential
applications for it. In my opinion, this is basic
academic research at its best. Bravo! I love it.
And, what would you use this for? Please
let me know in the comments below,
I’d love to hear your ideas. And until then, we
will have no more tangled earbuds in our pockets,
and we can thank computer graphics
research for that. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!